I'm just gonna I'll kind of help my case
a little bit let's take it off the shirt
I think
this would do
would do it oh man there it is
[Music]
you know what you can let's go we'll
rank the guys who took off their shirts
they're secure enough you have a great
physique man no I appreciate it straight
Captain America machine you know if
we're going based off looks I think we
should probably move up a little bit you
know bigger the better right we got the
money he has a crazy beard the beers
though yeah I got better hair though I
think that you guys run at each other
like full speed I think he's taking you
out so I think he's number one you can
stay out there I think I should move up
go ahead I think usually about he needs
to move up it's the beard bro I'm gonna
move up come on don't be modest all
right I appreciate it I still think you
guys switch let's do it
you guys do like the wave with your
packs oh wow
I'm gonna teach you guys something
you wanna see that all right Arnold I
see you
[Music]
do you think you're gonna bulk up after
this uh no I like being skinny yeah yeah
what we got out of this is that if you
have muscles a beard and a height and
luxury and Luscious Hair that is what
gets you testosterone pure science right
there I think we're good we'll get on
this yeah I think yeah
[Music]
let's talk about lifestyle what's the
lifestyle daily routine looking like so
I wake up at five in the morning get my
workout in gotta take care of your body
first because your body's a temple then
after that we go into like the whole
entire aspect of diet we ain't doing no
Donuts we ain't doing none of that no
cheesecake oh absolutely not brother
absolutely not so you're a baited if you
eat cheesecake
I want to move away from like this like
physical aspect like the working out and
stuff I think we should move away from
that you know I think there's like
personality that comes into it anybody
here like have stocks and bonds so I
feel like that's pretty like investment
is pretty Alpha I would say we own
houses they got stocks and bonds got all
that type of stuff because I always say
like if your finances aren't right you
ain't right especially if you got a
family if you got a girlfriend or
whatever your girl can't even trust you
with the finances so how are you really
knowful you're not yeah well I'm 19
right now so but I have stocks and bonds
I made 10 grand I put it in bonds like
immediately the day turned 18 because
then I want to be like old like you guys
and I got to be like doing like how do
you think
you guys are all like 40 right no it
feels like a sometimes Man black don't
crack that's true like they're all
ancient like old I like felt like these
are all like my old uncles like it was
actually horrible I felt like I wasn't
allowed to say like anything on my mind
or I was gonna get reprimanded they're
gonna tell my mom or something it was
crazy he's a sneaky one man Loki think
he has a he's probably just swimming in
the team and he's young too he's
swimming in the team bro he's young too
he's swimming to the team come on bro
listen next to you I think he's swimming
in the tea though you want me to be I'm
just saying like statistically when
you're 19.
do you vape no dude okay so what does
everyone do for a living I was in the
military and then now I'm a personal
trainer at a gym I started a private
Equity Firm about building skills
automotive shops I'm a bounty hunter I'm
an active by Dave podcaster by night but
I also work at a gym too I'm a dental
assistant uh just like at a tennis
office
I think we know we bodybuilders
they offer fashion I would say 100
Bounty Hunter oh yeah well no and also I
would I would definitely rank you up
there as well for activity levels and
all that stuff because you have to
motivate people
I mean you're young bro I'll go back up
it's fine
move back up to be honest wait I would
actually personally for me I would put
you probably number two or one let's
find one and then I'm hiding yeah and
he's acting too I'm tall too
I don't even need to do that he's
confident
I'm up and coming you put me number one
that's fine I'll do that I think I think
I'll look good
having high testosterone would you say
it's tied to your guys's ego absolutely
not no I don't know I don't really think
so I'll say no to be an alphabet I feel
like it's about dedication uh having a
driven work ethic you can have high
testosterone but if you're just sleeping
all day you know doing nothing with your
life you know then are you really but
like don't confuse like ego with like
confidence if that's a thing I agree but
that's the thing that like alpha male
like the term alpha male people get it
wrong I feel like everyone's like oh
they're uh egotistical bro they only
care about themselves it's just like
you're just confident who you are like
you don't need other people around you
you can just do your own thing it's the
way you hold yourself
how does sex drive play into being an
alpha
there's the sex hormone
I think it's a big indication I think
Tesla yeah
libido definitely does play into a
factory yeah if you have high
testosterone you know you tend to want
to you know get down a little bit more
so how many times y'all you know a week
I'm like Captain America all day
I mean at least one a day I'm gonna
clean the fifth on this one
how many times would you say monthly say
professional athletes don't have sex
like months some people do cut it off
that's BS that's some like some some Jim
bro was like making stuff up I mean like
for me personally out of respect for my
partner I'm not gonna get really into it
that's the right answer you guys bomb
that one bro y'all are done but I will
say I really think when that tea is just
going like the blood's pumping you're
like I need it touch it you're gonna
feel it no matter where you're at in the
house yeah bathroom maybe what's up real
quick
the question is if it's an alpha to have
high libido
well yeah you'd rather have high libido
than low libido right like you're gonna
have a high sex drive if you are keeping
up with everything with yourself right
but if you know we've all had days where
you're just like you know you don't even
do anything you get your T levels
measured that day
um it might not be the optimal
you know all this talk about working out
got me thinking what could potentially
be just as important your mental health
sometimes being a human is hard and we
need the right tools to help us be
stronger mentally and approach life with
a different perspective
which is why we're excited to tell you
about today's sponsor Better Health With
Better Health Therapy is more affordable
and accessible so you can find a
therapist regardless of the limited
options in your area to get the proper
help that you need what's great about
betterhelp is that it's online and
remote by filling out a few questions
Better Health can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as
few days it's easy to sign up and get
matched with a therapist sign up with a
link in our description at
betterhealth.com Jubilee media for 10
off your first month what if your
therapist doesn't rank as your number
one well you can
Rings is your number your number without
any stress
gosh that that's amazing
therapy take your first step at online
therapy with Better Health click the
link in the description or visit
betterhealth.com
are you born in alpha male or is it
something that you can learn to be I
think you learn from it from watching
mentors watching people you guys watch
on Andrew Taylor say that I'm gonna tell
you watch people like that like okay and
how do you carry yourself when bad
things happen let's say something does
fall you tend to like fall with it and
just cry about it or do you tend to like
run through it and actually become the
guy that you're supposed to be I think
being an alpha like it's a harness of
everything like your emotions just
everything so like when people are like
oh like stop you know stop crying
whatever I'm like I'm like bro if he's
he's in depth with his emotions and he's
able to hand those emotions and he's
able to say okay it's time to cry it's
time to I agree because I think that's
the biggest stigma especially for like
men because a lot of men are like oh
you're a beta because you're crying it's
like no bro like he's feeling some like
maybe he's more emotional but maybe he's
handling his business too because
sometimes like the most like the hardest
people like in the day they're like they
just gotta let it go because life life
is life life ain't fair so how you can
handle that my thing is the gym I I feel
bad no matter how I feel in my life I've
been through things where like I was a
fat kid then got heartbroken because of
that reason and then what got me into
like the whole controlling my emotions
with the gym if I'm angry
Jim if I'm sad Jim get it out of my mind
350 another Squat and just squat it out
see how that goes out you're not wrong
I'll put you over here because you and
maybe they're talking about Jim if you
feel bad you get straight up in the gym
left I don't do that all the time this
man down here though I don't know if you
all notice this man been directing the
flow of traffic back there and he's just
playing the cool he's like don't look at
me I should be up here plus the beard
it's just the beard I hear this
everywhere that's a sign bro the ladies
like they love the Luscious come on now
I'll take that I'll take the end again
if you wanna he'll tell you where I'll
take it back again
hey alpha males don't have you know
eagle
your children
confidence in the back bro you're real
holding it back I'm holding it down back
again okay I would say like
who's been on the year
who's tried it who's done it I've been
approached to do it but now I've never
done it right so you guys naughty or not
that's the question not not Maddie
you're not an added nope
really oh oh wow daddy
are you still on it when was the last
time you're on it
currently oh
[Music]
does using gear affect your opinion on
masculinity or being an alpha to me no I
don't think it does the way I see an
alpha doesn't matter how big you are
doesn't matter how you look honestly
you're not an alpha you're not a you're
not a role model in your life and your
family you're not that leadership role
you're not the protector the provider
that's not Alpha the only thing I say
about that is like I think it takes a
real like dog in there to be like I'm
gonna beat all these unnaughty people I
think you're not even giving yourself a
chance and no hate on him it's his is
medical like I get it but like I just
think in general too many people are so
baitish like they're worried about
everyone else so they're willing to like
inject like harmful chemicals into their
body it just doesn't make sense to me my
main goal since I've been probably six
was to be a professional bodybuilder so
I'm gonna get the one way or another
I don't really worry about negatives
from anybody else just do my own thing
but you know what I was do respect you
for being well he's honestly because
that's that's huge because there's a lot
of people acting like they're they're
natural when they're not that's Alpha
mentality but he's honest that's crazy
what is you guys definition of alpha
male I definitely think it's like you
are true to yourself and you like have
people looking towards you as a role
model and you're just independent like
you don't need other people to help you
I would just disagree on do it by
yourself I think every great leader
you're going to need help at some point
I think an alpha male you know takes
everybody's opinions and feelings into
consideration yeah I'll move down yeah I
think yeah
I'll stay back here I'll move up later
they were dogging on me for a second if
they said you can have people help you
which I think is I guess you can have
people help you if they help you along
the way
but I I really feel like it's
independent and being true to yourself
you don't need other people's so yeah my
last question is do you think anyone
here is not an alpha
you're still you're still young bro you
have a lot I mean you're
on the right path I'll tell you that
you're too loud right now in my opinion
you're too loud it's just my personality
and it's great trust me it takes you a
long way bro I think I'm just really
Charming but if you walk in a room and
being the loudest one it doesn't you're
still there not that he's not Alpha he's
developing okay to be the loudest dog
chew I was bark as long as they can but
you don't see a pimple looking back in
the scene let me let me let me bark back
at him no you guys are like like Mentor
me now is this what this thing is like
if you want one certain Alpha eventually
interventionally right now right now I'm
making training I'm in training I'm up
and coming
this look right to you guys
[Music]
this look where your Gucci good yeah
that's cool yeah I'll move later
I like that I like that
I'm gonna have Percy come to the back
because we don't have his results
so when we get his results we will do a
follow-up call where we will do the
final reveal because we'll have the
final ranking
um sorry Mama so
in the fifth spot
Adam
I told y'all I'm Natty I told y'all
well dude because you're cutting right
now your test is yeah you said you had a
show like in a month yeah I was
expecting it because
um with bodybuilding like I'm about four
weeks out and so I was like oh damn
they're actually gonna test that again
it's probably low as hell you had a big
old smile
he's swimming in it in the fourth spot
Drew
oh wow that actually surprised me okay
it was fun third Sam
I was a normal guy okay second Michael
and first Darren they're pretty good I
figured that was good let's go down the
line and say your numbers 329 529
546 725
this is a Dragon Ball Z moment bro
did you ever take a test before starting
tea do you know what your natural levels
look like uh 700.
wow so what's the difference between
having 700t up to 2000 T it really helps
with like
recovery you get sore like ever no wow
lucky like Captain America you still
have to work really hard like you still
gotta eat you still do the stuff but it
makes this whole unrealistic world of
professional bodybuilding attainable
because it's a lot of times it's it's
not natural it's the look of Health with
all it's but it's the life of sickness
yeah 100 now that a little bit of time
has passed where do you think Percy's
gonna fall a man is gonna be number two
I'll go number three let's do the final
ranking order in six was Adam with 329
in fifth
Percy with 517.
[Music]
fourth Drew with 529 third Sam with 546
second Michael 725 and first gear in
2182. so a person feeling knowing your
ranking order uh you know what this was
a battle of just minuscu points here
because you know from my ranking to
Sam's we're all like pretty close I'm
not too shocked uh right now I am trying
to get myself back in shape you know
I've been eating like crap so that I
probably did play a big part in it but
I'm a humble man that's why I have on
the sunglasses because I want I want to
show the tears as I'm starting to stream
down my face
so has this experiment changed anyone's
thoughts on their relationship between
testosterone levels and being an alpha
male
y'all are
okay no of course not I never really
Associated the two there's so many
factors that like you can manipulate
deal with testosterone the tests don't
make the man the man makes a test so I
don't know I actually like that though I
kind of like that